in this current age do you see more
students with this raw talent wanting to
what they call Hackett and and jump over
all the time that it takes to put in
because we're in this
it just feels faster and faster every
day maybe that's because I'm getting
older so it seems faster to me but do
you see that more now or no it's well
every right every writer wants to jump
over everything always as including
myself I don't consider myself to be a
terribly important writer although I'm a
much experienced one the Wall Street
Journal calls me a writer of substantial
professional experience and I have done
a lot of work in screen but not only in
screen I'm also the author of
best-selling fiction and nonfiction and
I've also written short films you know
commercials propagate corporate
propaganda sales films films for
instructional educational films the so
I'm hugely experiencing and I still want
to jump over all of the requirements but
every time I try to do that I realize I
can't that it just takes time and you
have to give it the time and that's the
most difficult part of it because after
all time is what your life is is made up
of and I mean time is like the currency
of life if somebody wastes my time
I feel they've killed me a little bit
you know they've taken part of my life
away and that's what art wants it wants
your life you have to you better be
ready to give your life to this if you
want to be a screenwriter it sounds
cynical and dark but I mean it the
opposite way I can't imagine a more
wonderful thing to give a life to then
creative expression imagine people who
do succeed as writers they're literally
swapping their daydreams for dollars
they're they're trafficking in their own
imagination what could be more wonderful
than that I think it's cause to to
rejoice not to despair but to rejoice
you